time for morning rounds from stem cell
therapies to editing our genes we've
seen no shortage of medical
breakthroughs in recent years but these
developments also raise ethical issues
and so do policy decisions about the
kind of care people get and how precious
resources are allocated it is all
discussed in the new book everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to die and we are joined by the authors
dr. Amy Gutmann and the president who is
the president of the University of
Pennsylvania and dr. Jonathan Moreno a
Penn professor we welcome both of you
thank you so much first of all two
questions here what is bioethics and why
did you decide to both write about it so
everybody cares about health care and
everybody's making decisions about
health care all the time and sometimes
they're really hard decisions for
ourselves and our loved ones and that's
really what bioethics about and what we
want to do is make sure people are
informed and prepared before crises
happen and I found out about that the
hard way when I was just 10 years old
when on a routine visit to my grandma
with my mom we found her in extreme
distress she was totally aware but in
enormous pain we rushed her to the
emergency room the next thing I knew my
mom was confronting a doctor who asked
my mom for permission to amputate my
grandma's leg and you know my mom said
at the spur of the moment you need to
get her permission to amputate her leg
and she told me afterwards that she
never would have forgiven herself had
she not done that so we want everybody
to be prepared and informed about much
greater decisions that exists now when
we started writing the book we realized
we both had stories like this in our
families and you're of a certain age you
remember those days the black bag toting
doctor came home and is very
compassionate we were talking about this
before house falls you know you've got a
couple of points remembering the term
but at the same time
the relationship between the doctor and
the patient was often kind of one-way
right
now people have more information and
they expect to be more part of their
decision-making and that's a lot of we
write about you were you also write
about dialysis and how the government
determined in the 70s that people would
get dialysis treatment Medicare paying
for it because this was life or death
but that plays into the bio ethical
debate now with other things it does and
you know we of course it's wonderful
that we take care of dialysis patients
people who have end-stage renal disease
we also though 40 50 years later start
to take more seriously the fact that
we're not covering well people who have
other serious diseases and so part of
what we want to do in the book is to try
to stimulate in this very partisan era a
conversation about how we go about
taking care of everybody who has a
serious illness and not just a
particular group that's been kind of
marked out historically what in your
estimation has to change right now you
talk about Obamacare and you you were
against repeal and replace Meuse a
should be revised and reinforced so what
what about the health care system right
now needs to be changed and what doesn't
so we really believe that if Americans
take more control over their own health
care and the health care of their
country things will go how do I do that
well many ways and you can read the book
but one way which we talk about is that
patients should come prepared when they
- their caregivers their doctors and
physicians and be prepared the open
about what you're doing with your
healthcare and also be clear about your
goals it's it's also something you talk
about in the book is asserting yourself
and asking those questions and if you're
not getting the answers continue to ask
and and and probe to find out exactly
what's happening to one of your
relatives or yourself most doctors are
very concerned obviously about their
patients they want to succeed they want
to be good health care providers they
want their patients to prosper and
thrive but in an era in which there are
so many options patients need to be
really more part of that conversation
I want to talk about some of the more
experimental treatments the gene
therapies the
you see so much in terms of technology
big data I mean where are we going or
where should we be going well
we're big proponents of innovation and
affordability both and we think we can
have both it one great example is which
is representative of what's happening
with immunotherapy and car t-cell
therapy is the case of Emily Whitehead
who seven years ago was really all the
treatments for her leukemia were used up
all the standard treatments and her
parents Tom and Emily Whitehead had to
decide whether basically she was going
to die because that was the case or to
look for experimental something
experimental and they chose the latter
they found car t-cell therapy it
happened to be at the University of
Pennsylvania but it's now now are no
longer an experimental treatment it's
actually fda-approved emily is a 14 year
old cancer-free young woman who has
become a champion with her parents race
[Music]
all kinds of fuels yes and it's just
balancing some of those things I'm sorry
that we're out of time a great debate to
continue and a great book for people to
read this affects all of us it does not
it's easier to read than we know thank
you very so much thank you